le centre au service scolaire de laval a
créé pour la rentrée une toute nouvelle
école une école virtuelle destinée aux
enfants du préscolaire du primaire et du
secondaire qui ne peuvent pas se
présenter en classe pour des raisons de
santé
ce qu'on tente de faire c'est que
virtuellement les élèves est une classe
comme s'ils étaient en présentiel donc
plus possible n'auront pas nous y aurons
pas de chaises mais tout ce qui va se
passer on veut que le rein ressemble à
ce qui aurait vécu six étaient à l'école
l'école virtuelle aura sa propre
direction ses propres enseignants les
élèves vont suivre un horaire bien
précis et ils seront toujours avec les
mêmes camarades de classe
si je prends l'exemple d'un élève de
sixième titre d'exemple mais nous avons
une journée qui vont sembler une journée
d'école standard syndicats vont oran
structure yves commencé à 8 heures ils
vont terminer à 13h30 et en fin d'après
midi c'était leur pouvoir poser des
questions plus spécifiques à des profs
et on promet que les élèves en
difficulté auront droit à de l'aide à
distance
on va embaucher des professionnels on va
voir des professionnels
quand j'ai professionnel je parle de
psychoéducateurs psychologues ou des
éducateurs spécialisés pour y inscrire
un enfant il faut fournir un billet du
médecin
les parents vont être invités à
transmettre le billet médical à l'école
de quartier donc l'école à laquelle sont
familiers et ensuite de seul processus
va être pris en charge pour que le plus
rapidement passer les élèves soit écrit
à l'école à distance du matériel
informatique sera prêté aux familles qui
en ont besoin et du soutien sera offert
aux parents pour mieux comprendre le
fonctionnement des différents outils
numériques
si l'idée est bien reçu des comités de
parents auraient aimé être consultés
avant la rentrée on trouve que c'est une
bonne idée mais il faut être impliqué
dès maintenant pour faire bonne mise en
cas d'éclosion l'école virtuelle restera
dédiée aux élèves qui ont un billet
médical si jamais il faut fermer une
classe où une école c'est
l'établissement visé par la fermeture
qui devra se transformer en espace de 24
heures en école virtuelle l'objectif
c'est de poursuivre l'enseignement à
distance mais toujours avec le même prof
et les mêmes camarades de classe ici
vincent maisonneuve radio canada
rien